the war in ukraine is having global
ripple effects and may lead to famine in
some areas local officials say that
ukrainian forces have been ordered out
of the last major city not controlled by
russia in a heavily bombarded region in
the eastern part of that country and now
the head of the u.n warns that food
shortages from the war may indeed lead
to multiple famines funding for aid
organizations has dropped during the war
especially in africa and that's where we
find our debra patters she's in south
sudan where it's estimated more than
half the population there over seven
million people are likely to face a
hunger crisis this summer
for nearly three years there's been
unprecedented rain in northern south
sudan
this country is on the front line of
climate change which has caused flooding
drought and famine exacerbated by the
war in ukraine
that war has sent food and fuel prices
soaring and drained funding to
organizations like the world food
programme
yabani kong knows what it's like to
stare death in the face she used to eat
once a day
now it's been a long time without food
she says i last ate two weeks ago her
home was flooded the water has still not
receded so she cannot plant the crops
they once lived off now this family of
five survives on wfp rations for two her
emaciated mother-in-law nyakong chang
doesn't know how old she is but she does
know she's never been this hungry before
i only get food when the united nations
comes she says
nibani's husband drowned last year and
she's already lost one child to hunger
now she's worried about 10 month old
baby chol and is your child getting
enough to eat
no she says i don't have enough breast
milk to feed her
baby chol is one of hundreds of
thousands of children relying on help
from wfp at a makeshift clinic mothers
bring their babies for assessment by
nutritionist monash
this is a quick way of checking
um
so we see she's already in the red
severely
i'm afraid you know
any child like that we are very close to
losing them
within days
with funding slashed wfp has been forced
to perform humanitarian triage by
cutting russians in half
many of these children should be
hospitalized but all nurses can do in
this remote location is provide meager
rations and tell them to return in a
week
for cbs mornings deborah pada
south sudan